a guy asked me in the QA when we moved
that we do a backstage VIP ticket and we
do question an answer with the backstage
VIPs at the smart smart money events and
he asked me he said we're getting ready
get married what do you recommend and I
said I recommend that you become a
student of things in your life that
matter if you're going to have children
and raise children you need to read
books by Meg Meeker on parenting if
you're going to be married you need to
read books by by button behind our
friendless parent you know on marriage
and and anybody else you get your hands
on on those subjects so I mean if you're
married for 20 years and you haven't
read at least 20 marriage books that's a
problem you know if you have a
two-year-old you should read at least
I've read at least two books on
parenting you know you oughta at least
average one book a year on a subject
that matters deeply to you if you want
to be a millionaire read some
millionaire books read the original
Millionaire Next Door read the new one
the next millionaire next door read Kris
Hogan's number one bestseller every day
millionaires compare the data compare
the conclusions of the data compare
what's going on with the you know the
different styles and writing styles and
so forth but become an expert on stuff
and you can do that by reading books you
could take a class you can do whatever
but you know you you don't just you know
kids and spouses don't come with manuals
and money doesn't come with a manual and
so you have to get the manual and the
Total Money Makeover and the legacy
journey and every day millionaires and
love your life not theirs and you can
start when you graduate with the
Graduate Survival Guide right I mean you
you know we've got the books here on the
money piece and other people do too and
we recommend lots of other people and
you know we're proud of the work that
Sarah is doing to continue her dad's
legacy there and it's incredible stuff
and the conclusions of that are you know
that they're finding the same things
that we found
and so it's no shock it's not like it's
some new conclusions but it is new data
it's fresh data and so um you know be
looking at it it's very interesting to
think about so you know just think about
that stuff and be you know what is it I
want to be really good at read books on
that you want to get in great physical
condition read books on getting in great
physical condition you want to you know
be a racecar driver
good read books on how to be a race card
and get the manual man I mean read study
study instead we become experts on a
Netflix series which benefits you how
I'm not against it I've watched two or
three series on the Netflix with my wife
in the last two or three months she gets
all up there about one of these things
and we watch them all the way through
it's nothing wrong with that but I mean
if that's the only thing you're putting
into your brain is watching other people
be successful or something screwed up
people that's a bad idea you know you're
entertaining yourself into oblivion so
grow your brain the Bible says don't be
conformed to this world don't be normal
but be transformed by the renewing of
your mind your mind is very powerful and
some people completely waste there's
different form of wasted but it's still
the same thing as the same result